you know in your book which uh i want to
talk about because it's fantastic you
say that alice is the source of many uh
well if tracy morgan's
lines yeah you actually your daughter
will say something and then you will
give it right to tracy morgan on the
show because it fits his character
perfectly sure yeah especially when
she's smaller it fits
perfectly like she
and i've seen some of her things like
she's she said i want to go to there and
we use that for for liz one time and she
with tracy we've had him say like touch
my knees butt which is some weird thing
that she used to say um
and i'm hoping that even though she came
here that would have some more there's
some more i'm wanting to use like for
example she still thinks that the plural
of ghost is ghostesses
that's perfect it isn't afraid of
ghostesses
and she had one recently that um
she was playing barbies i came and she
was playing barbies and she had
there's like a prince doll
of some disney prints and a barbie and
she the barbie had removed her pants
and was kind of angling toward the
prince and she's saying the dolls are
saying to each other you know the most
romantic part of the human body is the
butt
[Laughter]
and instead of being you know concerned
that that's what she's saying i was
gonna be like that's for tracy
that's the other point is you're not
really listening like a good mom no i'm
not a girl i'm having a lot of bad
dreams and something's really worrying
me that's perfect for tracy keep going i
can use that bossypants and um as i said
i really love the book and it was really
it's fun for me too because we have
something in common which is we both
really got started to to a good degree
at starting live writing at snl and so i
loved it when you were you were talking
about some things in the book that
brought back memories
for me you talk about the first time
that you met a host at starting out live
the first show that you worked on and
what a big deal because i remember that
being a huge deal yeah the first time
you're the first week you're there as a
writer you get called into this meeting
with the host and you know if my first
week the host was sylvester stallone
which is so i mean that's a movie star
you know like and you you can
you realize you get in this room and
you're sitting there waiting to talk to
them and you realize that movie stars
look different than regular people they
are sometimes a little tinier
and they have really nice teeth
and a really nice watch that's how if
you if you're around and you're like
trying to figure out that person is a
movie star yeah
most movie stars are and especially the
ones that kick ass for a living on
screen you see them and they you could
hold them like a baby yeah
yeah so that was my first week was was
mr stallone and i didn't get my own
sketch on but i got a sign to help with
a sketch which is something they make
the writers follow the performers around
and then the you sit um during the dress
rehearsal you sit next to lauren
michaels and if there's any he gives
notes and and he was saying to us some
i can't understand stallone to ask him
to enunciate more and so
the other writer i was with who had been
there longer than me was like uh you do
it
i didn't know anywhere so i was like
knocking on the hose door and it's so
scary to go in the host dressing room i
go in there and there's judge dredd just
like hey you know hang out
you know i call him rocky but i
understand every everyone has their own
frame of reference yeah over the top um
i uh i just had to go up to him and you
know and just be like um
and then read a sketch you were just if
you could announce it more and he was
just like because stammy
but he was so easygoing about it he's
like okay
he's like oh of course this is not the
first time in his life he's been given a
snow
and you realize that the the hosts they
just want to do a good job usually
they're like yes please tell me tell me
whatever i'll do whatever